how long should I be doing my right and my supplements? I am doing so much better.
What's hard to say, like, oh, I'm doing so much better by cancers and remissions, so I'm
going to stop doing the things that got me in remission. That's not always wise things to do. So,
you know, and years ago, I wouldn't emphasize that very much. Meaning, I wouldn't
want so much stress on a person to keep doing their right and keep doing their nutrition.
And I saw the negative results of that. I remember, you know, people coming back into what I had
a clinic and their cancer came back and David used their right for years. I just had somebody,
you know, recently sent David used their right for five years and now their cancers come back.
Well, would it have come back if they were still using the right but still taking their supplements?
Well, we don't know those answers to those questions. It just makes sense to me to continue to do
the things that got you into the state of remission in the first place, especially if it doesn't take
much time to do it.